welcome to the show a very special
Shanah Tovah to everyone who is
celebrating the new year today but even
that could not keep us away from the
show today
and good thing because so much happened
over the weekend to start with Donald
Trump has cracked over the weekend
tweeting about the same craziness about
impeachment including a ridiculous fox
news segment nearly 20 times alone there
close to a hundred tweets in total I
don't even know the exact number and
starting to suggest that his own
impeachment could lead to an American
Civil War we're gonna get to all of the
elements of this Donald Trump tweeting
endlessly a fox news segment that reeks
of desperation I am coining the term
adjectives a because the term agitprop
is not quite accurate it's a little too
Soviet in its connotations to describe
what it is that Fox News has been
displaying in defense of Donald Trump
against impeachment so I'm calling what
Fox is producing and Trump is tweeting
out better named adjutant ooh urban
dictionary Trump also threatening civil
war if he is impeached truly losing it
so let's look at this extraordinarily
childish embarrassing deluded behavior
of what is ultimately a panicked and
terrified man that's what we have today
in Donald Trump look at this non-stop
barrage of failed attempts at using the
English language by Donald Trump
including nearly a dozen tweets this
morning three tweets this morning about
Adam Schiff that make no sense enter
just the normal types of attacks we
would see normally from internet trolls
but this is the President of the United
States earlier with another three tweet
storm about China quoting known Trump
sycophantic brown-noser Maria Bartiromo
who have spoken about before and of
course raising the term witch-hunt that
puts us up to six tweets then he starts
tweeting anyone who will defend him he
will just retweet them anywhere that'll
get you retweeted by Donald Trump one
interview with
publican Kevin McCarthy who defended
Trump another of course would the
completely unhinged an outrageous
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham who
has become one of trumps a prominent
defenders another of Trump attorney Rudy
Giuliani Donald Donald Trump retweeting
that another TV segment from Lou Dobbs
on Fox Business were now up to ten
tweets and this is just the last nine
hours and this is all nothing compared
to what else happened on Twitter with
Trump then we go to late last night and
this is when Trump really was getting
himself wound up we're going sort of in
reverse chronological order in groups
here now with these I'm not going to
read every tweet because it's too insane
and it's just too much Trump attacking
Nancy Pelosi talking about impeachment
quoting Fox News and the radical left
and talking about Hillary Clinton and
going after the whistleblower these are
the endless unending tweets of an unwell
man and we are now up to 21 tweets about
this in the prior 12 hours 21 tweets and
then Trump goes on to the Fox News
adjutant and I encourage you to watch it
it's like close to 10 minutes long and
it featured this whacked-out right wing
or Mark Levin who's some I think it was
Sean Hannity who started calling him the
great one and it's like a completely
meaningless nickname and of course Mark
Levin defended Trump and said this is
all an unconstitutional attempt to
remove Donald Trump from power by a
means other than an election Trump
tweeted that segment endless times
hilariously sandwiched with a rosh
hashanah greeting in the middle not
counting that we are up to 24 tweets in
the last slightly more than 12 hours
related to Donald Trump's impeachment
and then I'm not going to get into this
in detail retweeting endless just random
people who went on Twitter and said Mark
Levin crushed it on Fox News I'm not
going to read each one but these are
just random
Trump sycophants who agree with a
clueless FoxNews agitate and innocent
Donald Trump is about 30 tweets of that
just random people who Donald Trump is
retweeting more than a dozen others were
talking about between the tweets and the
retweets and the adjectives Anor so
tweets here in total dating back to the
beginning of the weekend Trump just
retweeting anybody who's willing to
defend him on Fox News and retweeting
Twitter randos who are saying good
things about him and then the cherry on
top the specific threat of a civil war
going back to one of Donald Trump's
tweets and retweets quoting pastor
Robert Jeffress or Jeffress he's a
radical extremist himself who we've
spoken about before saying quote if the
Democrats are successful in removing the
president from office which they will
never be it will cause a civil war like
fracture in this nation from which our
country will never heal that's Donald
Trump quoting pastor Robert Jeffress via
Fox News on Twitter this is not the
behavior of a well person this is not
the behavior of an innocent person this
is not the behavior of someone who has
no interest in interfering or tampering
with witnesses in what is now an
increasingly popular impeachment inquiry
against Donald Trump which I will talk
about next
the only real debate I mean listen when
I look at this nearly a hundred tweets
over the weekend President of the United
States
I don't debate Wow does Donald Trump act
like an innocent or guilty person the
ship has sailed on that debate I don't
ask myself is Trump coherently using the
English language to communicate things
of meaning or is he not the guy is
completely incoherent that's not a
debate in my mind the only real question
I have is is the logical next place for
Trump to be removed from office and put
in prison or to be removed from office
and put in a mental institution and I
don't mean that satirically I don't mean
it to be in any way demeaning or
stigmatizing or making fun of actual
mental illness and I know a lot of
people get mad and they say David you
know
you're you're sort of insulting mentally
ill people when you say Trump may be
mentally ill he's just a terrible person
I don't know the answer this is not a
nun this is not a well person that's
what I can tell you the other remaining
questions are increasingly being
answered by these erratic and nonstop
tweets and the only question I have is
where is the logical next resting ground
for Donald Trump